[Music]
question party is very simple
we got tweeted questions and now we're
gonna answer them
okay grub hooligan asked
i just read that nbc is going to send
you to cover the olympics
congratulations what will you be
doing okay well i'm going to go to the
olympics
with jenny hegel and we're going to just
do fun little segments
and sketches and goofing around also
during the olympics there will be
coverage on nbc and there'll also be
coverage
on peacock and every morning there will
be a show called tokyo live
i'll be on that sometimes doing segments
goofing around
and like chasing down athletes that i am
in love with
and telling them so yay look i know you
are very strong
but i love you i
i love you too
that is very possible next question
at sk cage asked in which olympic event
do you think you could feasibly
participate and do
well oh my gosh what's sad is
their uh
sk cage's tv does not work it only has
audio because dang dude i'm
42 i can't do nothing
this is it and but if this
sitting yelling and enjoying a margarita
was an olympic event
buddy i would bring home the gold uh
no but honestly if what olympic
event would i do the best in i would
uh i did do gymnastics so i know for a
fact that ain't it
um i
if um cheerleading was
a olympic sport i could i could get in
there a little bit i could flip around
and yell and cheer yeah um
i mean i ran track and so i know that in
it uh
if dodgeball was an olympic event
i would have crushed dodgeball like
really i was impossible to hit
really i was like neo in the matrix like
just
if there was an olympic sport called
don't dodge ball where you had to get
hit
first i would definitely would
no but maybe if there was an olympic
event i had to
try and try to do well in i would do
climbing climbing um i would try
climbing i would try it
yes oof
i no i don't think there's anything
my body even at its peak like i
no i didn't do gymnastics as proficient
as you but like no
um tarik can do some gymnastics um
uh kip up to a handstand tara can
kip up to a handstand in a handstand
his feet are off the ground but like
like like this
that was pretty pre-pandemic carrying
his legs up
into a handstand just muscle it oh that
was pre-pandemic taric
now i can just do a handstand you guys
derek is my most athletic friend and i
am your least
athletic friend that's all the time we
have left for question party that was
great
let's do it again soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you